just because many screenwriters
directors and stars our way to the left
doesn't mean that films with libertarian
themes and messages don't get made here
are five great movies made over the past
25 years that any libertarian will enjoy
this Pixar film directed by Brad Bird is
so full of speeches extolling
individualism personal greatness and
self fulfillment it sometimes sounds
like it was scripted by Iran
dog you got me monologue in fact Rand is
clearly part of the inspiration for the
character of Edna modes the
libertarianism of the film exists on at
least two levels one obvious and one a
little more hidden but even the super
villain in The Incredibles is a creature
of self invention and self-improvement
while The Incredibles are born with
their powers syndrome is a Normie who
worships mr. incredible and is desperate
to be a sidekick crime fighting style
favorite cast freezes everything I give
me your number one fan when mr.
incredible dismisses young buddy he uses
that disillusionment to fire his
ambitions to create weapons and powers
via innovative technology like an
animated version of Richard Nixon
syndromes ambitions ultimately get the
best of him after all I am your biggest
fan but he just may be the real hero of
the movie at least for those of us
without naturally occurring super powers
The Incredibles are returning after a
14-year hiatus with a sequel hitting
theaters in June so we'll see them again
soon French Canadian director Denny
archons brilliant sequel to the decline
of the American Empire is the single
best depiction of the depredations of
socialized medicine economy the health
care system in the movie is so sclerotic
that the movies protagonist a retired
academic named Remi cannot even score
the drugs he needs to commit suicide
until his estranged bankers son buys
them on the black market policy stand
upon insist super Denis even more
disturbing is the moment when the
terminally ill Remi and his former
university colleagues admit that their
intellectual faddish Ness led them to
embrace every awful left-wing ISM of the
past 30 years
despite their often massive human tolls
Maui's it's this movie for this one Cuba
none of those drugs have been approved
by the FDA the screw the FBA
I'm gonna be be LA this based on a true
story movie about a rodeo rider in a
drag queen riding around the US Food and
Drug Administration brought home Oscars
not just for its two leads but the
film's makeup artist who reportedly
worked on a budget of just 250 dollars
set in the 1980s Matthew McConaughey
plays Ron Woodruff of boozy roughneck
who was given 30 days to live after
being diagnosed with AIDS faced with
such a death sentence he schools himself
on a wide variety of treatments first in
Mexico and then all over the world with
the help of a cross-dressing party girl
named rayon Woodruff skirts FDA
prohibitions against importing using and
selling unapproved drugs by creating a
buyers club in which members pay a
monthly membership and assume all risks
now you're the [ __ ] drug I mean
goddamn people are dying the depiction
of indifference to patients suffering
and bureaucratic washing of medical
freedom even for people who are certain
to die is unsparing deeply moving and
totally inspirational especially now
that even Donald Trump has endorsed
right to try legislation that would
allow terminally ill patients access to
non approved medicines my name's
Jennifer Lawrence became a megastar
playing the anti-government rebel
katniss everdeen in the Hunger Games
Movies and while there's no shortage of
libertarian sentiment coursing through
that trilogy it's actually a quieter
movie starring Lawrence that fully
embodies libertarian virtues of hard
work commercial innovation and dogged
entrepreneurship enjoy Lawrence plays
real-life miracle mop inventor joy
Mangano who helped make cleaning your
floors a little bit easier and better
while becoming wealthy at the same time
the film is nothing less than a payin to
capitalism's genius at allowing
self-expression as the story begins joy
is supporting a wide variety of family
layabouts while barely making ends meet
but she's firm with her daughter about
what really counts in a dramatic scene
with Bradley Cooper who plays an
executive at a home shopping netwerk joy
summarizes in a few centons what it took
Joseph Schumpeter Friedrich Hayek and
Milton Friedman whole books to say you
said to me that David Selznick the son
of immigrants married Jennifer Jones an
all-american girl from Oklahoma because
in America all races and all classes can
meet and make whatever opportunities
they can and that is what you feel you
reach into people's homes with what you
sell as form a reason editor of Virginia
passed railroad of joy the film
acknowledges the wealth creating value
of incremental improvements even in the
most mundane items it was first released
in 1984 Ghostbusters quickly became the
most successful comedy in film history
in many ways the movie was perfectly in
sync with the Reagan revolutions
valorisation of business and
demonization of government out of
college you don't know what it's like
out there
I've worked in the private sector they
expect results Ghostbusters begins with
the team of paranormal investigators
getting kicked out of Columbia
University for well being [ __ ]
artists they're forced to start their
own risky business venture filling what
they believe is an underserved market
niche even though New York is literally
being invaded by evil spirits the true
villain of the movie is not the
otherworldly demon Gozer but an
environmental protection agency
bureaucrat named Walter Peck but of
course the Ghostbusters ultimately
persevere save the city and turn a good
buck in the process we're gonna have to
ask you for four big ones $4,000 for
that but we are having a special this
week on proton charging well what do you
think it's by no means an exhaustive
list so add your personal favorites in
the comments and don't forget to tell us
just how wrong we are either
[Music]
[Music]